[Music]
well here we are one day before the
release of a big new Zelda title and I'm
still occasionally pinching myself to
see if I'm not dreaming I feel like I've
gone through at least four different
life phases while waiting for this game
in the time between announcement and
release I was engaged I moved house
became the proud owner of four chickens
and a dog and most notably I became a
YouTuber in fact tomorrow's launch
roughly coincides with the three-year
anniversary of monster maze not to the
exact day but it's pretty close some of
you may have noticed that I've gone a
bit quiet since my last video about the
eighth heroine and there's a couple of
reasons for that first is of course the
fact that the game itself has leaked
about two weeks ago and I would hate to
get the experience ruined for me so
close to the Finish Line I mean they're
spoilers and then there's like here's
the whole game you know what I mean as
such I've been avoiding places like
Twitter and other social media including
the comment section on my own videos
which has been quite painful because I
love engaging with my audience but
unfortunately it's come to this this as
much as I consider this my job now I'm
still set on experiencing the game at my
own Leisure and I finally reached the
point where I feel like I've seen enough
I'm even skipping Nintendo's Treehouse
live stream for that same reason aside
from that I also figured that this might
be the last chance I get in at least a
good few months to take it easy because
despite the title of this video this is
of course not the end of the journey
well it's the end of the journey when it
comes to waiting for tears of the
Kingdom but in terms of creating content
a whole new one is about to begin this
was just phase one folks a very lengthy
phase one mind you but you know I'll
talk about what you can expect from me
as far as a schedule goes near the end
of all this rambling but for now I just
wanted to say thank you to each and
every one of you thank you for getting
the channel where it is now when I
started making my own Zelda videos three
years ago I never expected in a million
years that this would take off the way
it did for the majority of the Channel's
existence I was still doing corporate
animations on the side to make ends meet
and I kinda expected it to stay that way
a 50 50 split between Don motion which
is actually the name of my company and
making video videos about my favorite
video game series as Monster maze but
since more or less last year I've been
able to drop the corporate stuff
entirely and solely focus on YouTube
which has been an absolute blessing
obviously making Zelda videos is way
more fun than making advertisements for
a law firm or a soft drink since when it
comes to my channel it's all on me I get
to decide my own deadlines how my videos
will look and sound and what subjects to
dive into which is exactly the type of
Freedom I've been looking for and I will
never take this for granted despite
dropping the corporate stuff and
focusing on Monster maze I've actually
been working more hours than I ever did
before whether it's coming up with a
theory doing research writing a script
and recording a voiceover animating
stuff or playing Ocarina of Time for the
zillionth time to capture footage of
that one specific thing I'm basically
working close to every day including
weekends however it doesn't feel like it
to me because Zelda is my comfort zone
it's one of a few things in my life that
managed to consistently stick with me
most of my past interests like
skateboarding or trying to become a rock
star or a pro Counter-Strike play player
have all perished within just a few
years because I simply lost my passion
for it in most cases for good but my
love for Zelda survived through all of
it it's been a driving force behind my
own creativity for a very long time and
whenever I worked on something Zelda
related it never felt like actual work
if that makes any sense just to give you
an example here's a video I made back in
2005 when I was 18 years of age I'm
almost 36 now by the way this is
essentially the first quote-unquote
viral video I ever made and it just so
happens to be a Zelda video it clocks in
at about 300 000 views which for the
time was an absolutely insane number and
it even won the daily feature award as
you can see sure it looks pretty
terrible for today's standards but this
was months and months of work at the
time especially given the hardware
software and tools we had back then most
of this stuff was drawn frame by frame
with a mouse by the way and it was my
love for Zelda that made me crazy enough
to do it but it doesn't matter how old I
get I will always be super excited for a
big new Zelda game it really is
something special particularly because
they're so few you and far between tears
of the Kingdom despite not even being
out yet is in a way already my favorite
Zelda experience ever now I've been
around for a while so I'm no stranger to
waiting for a new Zelda game to come out
I vividly remember waiting for the Wind
Waker which at the time felt so
excruciatingly long but as a content
creator it's definitely a different
experience I've essentially been holding
a magnifying glass to this project from
start to finish for three solid years
four if you count my time as an editor
for the Commonwealth realm I've been
living and breathing Zelda day after day
trying to figure out what the game is
all about and come up with interesting
topics to dive into while I have done
plenty of videos about other Zelda
titles and even non-zelda content as
well monster maze is and always will be
a channel that found its roots in the
era of anticipation for tears of the
Kingdom in fact the video that put my
channel on the map to begin with was
about trying to figure out the
chronology for the 2019 trailer and well
I guess tomorrow we're gonna see how
well that's gonna age given how long ago
I made it and how much has changed about
the game since probably not very well
but hey at least I had fun making it and
like I said I owe much of My
quote-unquote Success to this video that
said I hope you're all going to enjoy
tears of the Kingdom to the fullest I
cannot wait to hear all of your unique
experiences and how you went about
solving certain puzzles or which areas
you visited first and what you found
there it's going to be legendary and I'm
confident that we'll be talking about
this game for many more years to come
from what we can tell it's at least
twice as big as breath of the wild was
and that game still gave us stuff to
discuss and things to discover even six
years later so yeah I think it's gonna
be fine when it comes to my uploads in
the coming weeks and months safe to say
it's gonna be a little longer before I
start putting things out there as I said
I'm gonna allow myself to experience the
game as a gamer first content creator
second so expect at least two maybe
three weeks of Silence before I go on to
create regular content I'm sure this
won't be a big problem for many of you
since you'll likely be playing the game
yourself and you owe it to yourself to
experience it in your own unique way
without story spoilers without someone
else telling you where to go first my
advice with these types of games will
always be just go out there there and
have fun and by the time we're all ready
to talk about it we will at Great length
as for streaming I might stream on
occasion but it's going to be sporadic
at best simply because for the first
playthrough I prefer to experience games
like these on my own as much as humanly
possible besides I kind of suck at video
games anyway so there will be way better
choices out there if you want to enjoy
watching someone else play the game once
again thank you so much for everything
really whether you're a patreon a
channel member or just a regular viewer
I owe each and every one of you a great
deal which reminds me I've been a bit
behind on the new patreon and member
shout out so since I'm gonna be silent
for the next few weeks this is as good a
time as I need to catch up as such a
very warm welcome to Mad bakoblin MMG
Samuel reiswak Pebble Stephanie cater
big man James Professor Clover Lu JT
Miss adik Hylian Knight Trav does weird
things Sean Swift shade Gabby Medrano
Gwyn Oaks Jacob Keeley Slurpee Fusion
Diesel draculus and Shannon Quinn I hope
I didn't butcher any of that anyway
thank you all so much for your
generosity it's been hard to keep up
sometimes since some people change their
screen name on occasion or I'm just a
blind idiot who's too focused on a
project at the time so if I happen to
forget anyone please let me know down in
the comments and I'll try to make it up
in the first video I put out after
release day well I guess that's all from
me for a little while again I hope you
all have a great time and I will see you
on the other side bye bye
[Music]
foreign